So here's the Folk Theorem. Any feasible payoff
profile that strictly dominates the minmax or security
level profile can be realized as a Nash
equilibrium payoff profile, with a sufficiently large discount factor.
>> Prove it.
>> What we're going to do is we're going to construct a
way of behaving where both players are going to play
so that they achieve this feasible profile. And the reason
to make that a Nash equilibrium, what we need to do
is make it so that it's a best response. And the
way that we are going to make it a best response is
we're going to say do what you're told. Follow, follow your instructions
to achieve that feasible payoff. And if you don't, then the
other player is going to attack you, is going to adopt
a strategy that forces you down to your minmax or security
level, and that's your threat. So the best response to that
threat is to just go along and, and and do what
you're told to achieve that feasible payoff. The only
way that that's going to be stable though is if the
thing that you're asked to do, the feasible payoff, is
better than the minmax, right? Because that has to be
a threat. You can't threaten somebody and say, you know,
do this or I'm going to give you candy. It's gotta
be do this or I'm going to do, give you something
that's less pleasant than what I've asked you to do.
>> Okay, that actually makes sense.
>> Yeah, so this is, this is a really cool idea.
>> I like it. Hey, could you try saying that again,
but with a Southern accent, just the Folk Theorem part?
>> Any feasible payoff profile that
strictly dominates the minmax/security level profile can
be realized as a Nash equilibrium
payoff profile with sufficiently large discount factor.
>> I like that because now it's a folksey theorem. [LAUGH]